savez-vous ce conte en commun paul
newman et raymond barre charles aznavour
et charlton heston
marlon brando et michel tournier tous
les six ont vu le jour en 1924
ils atteignent donc cette année les 75
ans ainsi que le relève tournier dans
son récent ouvrage célébration un
ensemble de 82 texti kull c'est ainsi
qu'il appelle ses courses décès paru au
mercure de france
tournier est un esprit paradoxal et
singulier qui connaît une destinée
littéraire inaccoutumée un douloureux
échec à l'agrégation de philosophie
écarte ce germanistes de la carrière
universitaire il bricole à la radio et
dans la photographie avant que de se
lancer à 40 ans révolus dans la
littérature publiant coup sur coup en
huit ans trois grands romans vendredi ou
les limbes du pacifique
le roi des zones et les météores dans
lesquelles il approfondit trois thèmes
de la culture occidentale
robinson l'ogre et les jumeaux à 50 ans
michel tournier est un classique
s'il n'a jamais depuis retrouvé cette
veine profonde tournier poursuites ici
un agréable vagabondage littéraire
autour du quotidien heureux habitants
d'un presbytère de la vallée de
chevreuse
il observe la forêt aux petites heures
se demande où les hérissons passent
leurs journées disserte sur les routes
15 elle est tatouée et remarque que
toutes les civilisations ont en commun
un aliment d'une grande faveur dont le
nom s'orthographie en trois lettres le
blé pour l'occident le mille pour
l'afrique et lurie pour lorient
e